nouvel épisode de la série dans son
corps dans laquelle des invités viennent
me parler de leurs particularités
physiques
aujourd'hui je reçois ben de la chaîne
nota bene et il vient nous raconter une
drôle d'histoire
l'histoire nota bene
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben et auteur réalisateur et youtube
heures sur la chaîne nota bene où il
parle d'histoire salut benz halluin ça
va ça va très bien merci
quelle est ta particularité à toi ma
particularité c'est qu'il ya un enjeu
laitiers des gnostiques et comme faisant
de l'apnée du sommeil
de manière assez grave c'est à dire que
tout le monde fait la tenue au sommeil
mais en gros en dessous de 15 à fne par
heure on considère que c'est normal
entre 15 et 30 on commence à te dire raf
au revoir un peu tournaisienne de vie et
puis au delà de 30 ça va t équipée d'une
machine pour t'aider à respirer la nuit
mais quand et à combien
ah bah écoute mon pneumologue et m'a dit
que j'avais pété son record des gars qui
menaçait la machine aussi puisque je
suis à 93 appelé par huawei ses nerfs
les gens qui font des apnées du sommeil
n'ont pas conscience donc on met parfois
un moment à faire le diagnostic le
syndrome peut être de léger à sévère
mais cas d'éclatement à chaque pause
respiratoires on se réveille donc le
sommeil est agitée et de mauvaise
qualité du tout la journée on est
fatigué et souvent irritable même si on
a dormi longtemps et est ce que tu peux
tu peux me raconter brièvement comment
tu t'es rendu compte que tu avais que
thales a rétrospectivement en fait ça
fait quand même pas mal de temps parce
que
ce fait douze ans que je travaille dans
l'audiovisuel et il ya déjà douze ans
mes petits copains de 1 watt de prendre
s'amuser à collectionner des photos le
mois qui dormait un peu partout ok donc
dans le bureau il y avait des photos de
moi en train de dormir dans le métro
avec l oms sa caméra ou à l'arrière de
la caisse ou entre deux prises va et
avec le temps les premiers symptômes
sont apparus et là c'est
surtout de la fatigue extrême en fait je
suis devenu quasiment narcoleptique donc
j'étais le relooker arrivé en soirée tu
vois je me posais j'étais bien et puis
on arrivait à table et je m'entends
matin en fait où j'allais chez les potes
et puis je me caler dans leur canapé est
en fait mon temps mais je me réveillais
deux heures après ils ont inventé
laisser dormir parce que voilà ça a été
les difficultés aussi de plus en plus
fréquente de prendre la bagnole pour
faire des longs trajets ou là je te dis
de m'arrêter toutes les demi-heures des
fois tu vas dormir 15 minutes de
repartir
donc tout le temps crever puisse lever
le matin et en fait penser à l'instant t
en fait ce qui se passe avec l'appui du
soleil
c'est que tu te poses pas la donne
puisque tu entres jamais dans le sommeil
profond
vu que tu t'arrêtes de respirer en fait
alors moi c'était les apnées la sema
c'est ma femme qui m'a vraiment poussé à
aller voir un médecin parce qu'elle me
disait tu arrêtes de respirer les nains
et je suis là ce vendredi
et puis une fois deux fois trois fois
que je la croyais pas trop et un jour
elle m'a enregistrés et amar diffuser
cet extrait voilà où j'ai arrêté de
respirer pendant 45 secondes chose que
je n'arrive pas à faire la paix sinon
voilà donc ça va un peu fait flipper et
médecin m'a dit mais en fait c'est comme
si vous faisiez un marathon tous les
soirs parce que finalement le coeur
quand tu t'arrêtes de respirer tu
t'arrêtes de respirer donc le coeur
essaye de pomper un peu plus pour
envoyer la la le pâté et puis ensuite
moi tu que tu te réveilles et puis ça
recommence et marathon vous faites tous
les soirs dans votre coeur et ils
commencent à s'épuiser et apple
justement parce que c'est une idée des
complications il ya le fait de
s'endormir tout le temps d'être fatigués
la journée plus ou moins d'avoir du mal
à se concentrer et machin tu peuvent
avoir aussi des problèmes cardiaques
à terme si c'est pas prêt à temps il
tombe un peu à moi il m'a dit carrément
que dans dans l'état là où j'étais
soit negra en fait super une douzaine
d'années de vie en fait il m'a dit
c'était pire que clap et alcool quoi
donc c'est une multiplication du coût
des risques d'avc donc le cerveau le
coeur qui prend très cher aussi
et puis tu as donc les somnolences tu as
aussi des pertes d'attention perte de
mémoire très fréquentes
donc voilà ça on sent vraiment plein
plein de choses
et donc tu es fatigué tu récupères pas
quand tu commences à d'apnée du sommeil
souvent les patients sont un peu en
surpoids avoir beaucoup en surpoids ben
j'étais beaucoup sur quoi et du coup le
premier truc qu'on me dit quand tu es
d'athènes sommeil c'est la revois ton
d'hygiène de vie
ça y est de mieux manger essaye de faire
du sport voilà moi dans mon cas le
médecin m'a dit e fois que vous le
fassiez mais ça va pas changer les
quelque chose presque à ce stade-là de
façon c'est mort quoi je vous en ferai
toujours et en plus c'est ça ça m'a
vachement touchés ont fait des erreurs
que c'était héréditaire parce que moi
mon père est mort d'une crise cardiaque
à 43 ans ouais et j'ai jamais trop su
pourquoi on ne savait juste dit bah
c'est une crise cardiaque comme ça
voyant qu'elle ait jamais le symptôme
avant et tout mais moi j'ai souvenir de
mon père un peu avant de mourir il s'est
toujours je suis fatigué je choisis les
juges fatiguée et je pense c'est une
conviction personnelle en fait j'ai
aucune preuve tangible mais qu'il était
aussi victime de paix du sommeil et que
sap a été diagnostiquée puisqu'en fait
l'apnée du sommeil c'est très
difficilement d'agnostiques parce que tu
te rends pas compte
il faut vraiment quelqu'un d'autre à
côté et conscience de ça et te mettre
devant le fait accompli
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand
même beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
d'apnée du sommeil et qui ne sont pas au
courant et donc ça vaut le coup de
pouvoir se faire
des pistes et moi je sais que quand une
fois que je me suis fait dépister et
donc j'étais équipé d'une machine bah du
coup j'ai ma belle mère qui a été j'ai
un pote aussi j'en ai parlé avec lui il
y a été aussi voilà ça a déclenché une
réaction
le dépistage du coup toile en ce qui
concerne ils t'ont fait un monitoring
c'est ça en gros du coup ils m'ont jeté
des électrodes tout ça et puis ils ont
analysé le sommeil voilà ils ont pu
voler leur petit relevé qu effectivement
je vais arrêter de respirer
donc les signes temps en temps à parler
c'est vraiment fatigue fatigue extrême
tendance à s'endormir un peu partout
troubles de l'attention troubles de la
mémoire
irritabilité parfois même je suis
rassuré car ça c'est des trucs que toi
tu peu d'épicés chez toi mais tu as
aussi comme ça a été ton cas c'est
souvent le conjoint ou la conjointe qui
dit alors tu ronfles quand même beaucoup
et puis des fois tu t'arrêtes vraiment
de ronfler mais même de respirer pendant
très longtemps donc il ya aussi faire
pour les gens qui sont qu'ils sont en
couple souvent tata le signal d'alarmé
est tirée par jour c'est vrai que tu
ronfles comme un porc aux six mois
j'étais j'étais très au championnat et
mesurer une fois je suis 90 décibels ps
bref enfin c'était chiant c'était je
suis pour ma femme en panne et bon du
coup c'est aujourd'hui je m'en fou le
plus laisser respirer par un autre bruit
ouais ouais alors du coup tu as tu as
été tabuteau monitoring le diagnostic et
on t'a donné la taille de machines
d'abord donc il ya un type qui est venu
chez moi explique ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la poignée du sommeil on est
le seul pays au monde qui considère que
l'apnée du sommeil si maladie qui est
handicapant qatar pour le travail au
quai et donc c'est le traitement de
l'apnée du sommeil est remboursé par la
sécu et on est le seul pays au monde qui
en bourse sous traitement c'est bien que
moi là la machine que j'ai qui est
relativement petit
il ya 20 30 ans étaient des gros trucs
et donc les gens peut être encore cette
image là c'est vraiment petit parce
qu'aux états unis notamment les gens ne
peuvent pas trop se payer un suivi
médical
donc il faut des petites machines qu'ils
soient friendly
utilisation et où donc donc voilà est
donc cette machine là en france on te la
donne pas tu l'achètes par en fait parce
que tu as un organisme qui gère ces
machines là qui est directement en
rapport avec ton médecin et qui vient
chez toi qui te présente la machine et
rockit là prête enfin qu'il alloue mais
sous toi tu te goures travail voilà
c'est la sécurité y est donc cette
personne at expliquer un peu comment ça
ça fonctionne donc en gros tu mets un
masque sur le nez il ya des gens qui ne
supportent pas et qu'ils doivent aussi
avoir la bouche il respire par la brèche
et le principe de la machine c'est que
ça envoie une pression d'air continu que
toi tu as dans pif pour maintenir les
voies
respiratoires dégagé parce qu'il ya
plusieurs types d'apnée du sommeil
il y en a qui ont des causes
neurologiques alors la faute et je crois
qu'il ya des machines vraiment spécial
qui existe mais je vois moi c'est de la
tenue mécanique c'est à dire que l'on
grosse c'est le la gorge qui va se
serrer et ne souffrent plus et là le
principe de ça donc c'est d'envoyer de
l'air vraiment continue ce qui fait que
ça peut pas se fermer de la trachée
restent ouverts roi tu fort exactement
et donc c'est une première impression tu
te dis merde je dois reporter ça toute
ma vie vraiment parce que les les cinq
premières secondes quand tu le mets
c'est très étrange quand tu expire thème
de la requérante web le sens à double
sens c'est bien aussi que si je porte la
machine alors aujourd'hui j'essaie de
trouver quelques petites techniques qui
me permettent de dire quelques mots
quand j'ai demandé à le masquer mais
sinon si j'ouvre la bouche à un flux
d'air contiennent tout savoir c'est
cambrai et kanté question con mais quand
est enrhumé quand elle n'est boucher ou
talent une équipe où le machin projeter
là le truc dans le fond de la gorge wes
un peu c'est un peu chiant il faut bien
bien se moucher avec et quand tu es
vraiment très très enrhumé tu peux pas
porter la machine
donc ça c'est bath compris qu'il faut
vite se soigner moi pour l'instant j'ai
eu du bol ça fait un an que je suis
équipé en un an
honnêtement j'ai peut-être un soir j'ai
pas pu la mettre mais sinon le ballon
même content rue mais bon le fait que tu
adler justement peut-être ça aide un peu
a dégagé à respirer quand même je ne
sais pas tout nouveau fonds de l'avs
auraient encore moins avoir la bouche
parce que sinon tu fais une l'exorciste
ccr et ben écoute on va là on va la voir
cette cette machine je te la passe pièce
pop
donc ça se présente sous cette forme
donc moi j'ai une petite machine donc le
vraiment sur ma table de nuit à m c'est
pas très très très récents et donc voilà
ça se met sur le net a vraiment l'air
d'un con ça c'est ça c'est pour
reprendre appui sur le le ferons ouais
c'est ça après tu te passe-t-on du pass
pass 3 langlois et après hop tu colles
comme ça comme ça et tu respires et
bon c'est sûr faut s'y habituer ouais si
tu as envie de les chausser pas ouf
c'est pas le premier soir j'ai dit non
non tu essaies de pécho avant de mettre
je mettrais bien voilà c'est prêt vert
parce que ça peut faire ça peut faire un
peu peur au début alors quand je disais
que ça peut faire beaucoup de bruit
surtout si à un moment donné ça se sache
ce bar parce que mon moelleux et bien
adaptées dont il ya pas de fuite serait
mais tu peux garder toute la nuit pour
qu'elles si jamais un moment donné tu te
retournes sauvagement janser le masque
ce barge je peux te dire que tu te
réveilles parce que ça fait ce bruit là
on est sur un bon aspirateur on est sur
un bon aspirateur le truc c'est que ça
fait quand même moins de bruit quand une
mère avait sauvé puis oui oui le moteur
fait zéro brusseleir qui sorte qu'il
fait du vrai quoi voilà donc mon là je
l'éteins hockey du coup c'est une autre
sorte de bruit n'est pas moi ma compagne
me dit que on ment aux cinq au départ
simple chien aussi mais ça tu as plus de
ronflement est injuste ce bruit de
machine de respiration qui est quand
même plus supportable le déroulement ou
des faits des pics des trucs tous et
passera constant là c'est un briquet
constant et du coup tu ronfles pas alors
pour le coup je faisais moi les fuites
ça va surtout les premières nuits pour
s'habituer impôts masque mais maintenant
j'en ai plus quoi voilà c'était juste la
première nuit
je me souviens bien je dormais en
regardant la paille comme ça et en fait
tu as une sortie d'air qui est prévu par
ici et du coup elle se prenait tout
l'air dans la tronche et a du coup le
lendemain les 3 2 voilà donc faux faux
faux juste et d'éviter ça mais tu prend
vite des réflecteurs
c'est un coup c'est un coup à prendre
c'est un coup à prendre et le truc c'est
que encore une fois j'ai beaucoup de
chance parce que c'est le masque le
moins invasif
ouais et en plus de ça quand tu portes
un masque ça peut être asséchés
totalement les le nez et la gorge
il ya des gens qui supporte pas ça et
donc en plus de la machine derrière tu
as un bloc moteur qu'il faut remplir de
flotte que nettoyer tous les jours ce
qui est forcément ancien enseignant les
magazines donc donc c'est chiant cette
machine là elle est douée par un
prestataire qui est en relation avec le
médecin et c'est une machine qui est
connecté à tula connectathon wifi
simplement et en fait ça on voit des
rapports toutes les nuits à ton médecin
donc ça c'est plutôt pratique parce que
lui peut suivre quand même de loin son
état à voir si un problème avec la
machine ou pas pareil pour la personne
qui affirme que l'entreprise qui qui
loue la machine toi tu peux avoir des
rapports sur ton téléphone portable
aussi ok histoire de vérifier que par
exemple t'as pas des fuites toutes les
nuits de
des routes rend pas compte et auquel cas
tu peux y remédier en mettant des
sangles voilà et puis en plus d'être
connecté
il faut dire voler préparent ensemble
tous pas mal hein par machine par contre
on n'y pense pas mais ce qui est est ce
que je pensais que tu as devant
l'adversité
ouais bah ouais y'a pas de batterie il
n'y a pas de batterie donc typiquement
soit quand je suis allé au hellfest
ah ouais et bien en fait je pouvais pas
le camping bah ouais je peux pas le
camping parce que je m'étais renseigné
il m'avait fourni relate batteur que tu
peux brancher sur une batterie de
bagnols mais ça une batterie de bagnols
va tenir une nuit ou un peu moins tueur
est donc c'est chaud et j'étais obligé
de prendre une tante chez l'habitant
pour avoir une rallonge à travers tout
le jardin pour respirer dans mon coeur
bat donc le pop le camping sauvage tu
vois moi c'est ça votre phobie
tu dis que ça fait un an que tu es que
telle équipe et ça fait un an je suis
équipé et depuis je joue a carrément
carrément le changement les premiers
jours c'est assez spectaculaire et
d'ailleurs je crois que les premiers
jours ou pas le deuxième jour j'ai pu
jeter écrits directs en disant juin je
vois là j'étais malade j'en ai je suis
équipé ses formidables et et ma femme a
dit oui au calme toi ça se trouve c'est
juste le début du traitement attend de
voir et je vais finir par exemple sur
balles un peu et c'est vrai que les
premiers jours je ne sois le lendemain
j'ai une vision très claire de moi qui
parcourt toute la baraque avec une
énergie mais incroyable je soulevais les
meubles faisaient tout le ménager en
retourne et où toute la maison parce que
j'avais une énergie incroyable
c'était la première fois depuis les
années que je dors bien et ouais c'est
vrai c'est vraiment posé la libération
et depuis
bon bah voilà ça m'arrive maintenant
d'être d'être fraude aussi mais c'est de
la vraie fatigue quoi c'est pas mal ça
donc j'ai retrouvé une vie normale où je
peux faire
de la bagnole et puis je m'endors pas le
temps non plus dans les canapés ouais
moi la wka table où j'ai pu cgp eu ce
genre de problème
tu as l'impression que tu avais d'autres
trucs dont on parlait tout à l'heure
concentration mémoire machin à tous est
affectée pas trop en avant en fait moi
je titre perso j'arrive pas à me rendre
compte pour elle mais les gens me disent
que je suis effectivement je suis chez
air plus concentré que je suis plus
vivace couac est en tout cas dans mon
environnement immédiat
tous mes potes m'ont dit waouh t'as faim
tu as changé en bien puisque là quand tu
retrouves de l'énergie un truc quoi tu
es moi je suis avec les autres le là
pour toi le déclencheur en tout cas ce
qui t'a poussé à consulter
c'est quand ta femme fait écouter ton
était problèmes de respiration la nuit
mais du coup toi aussi tu as vers un
conseil à donner à quelqu'un qui bouge
pas à qui se sont creusées machin etc
soit 2 en parler à son médecin
s'il est tout seul effectivement s'il
n'y a pas de conjoint
identifiés font parler au médecin appui
dans le doute
voir s'il ya moyen de faire un test ou
pas je pense que c'est pas mal parce
qu'il ya quand même a priori beaucoup de
gens qui en souffrent et qu'ils le
savent pas et qui en souffrent pas ou
degré où je peux être atteint mais qui
tue peuvent en souffrir
et c'est guérissable ce qui suffit
vraiment de 2,2 de changer les habitudes
alimentaires ça peut aller ça peut aller
vite finalement quand c'est pas s'est
passé pas très élevé au niveau de
l'indicé moi je vois un moment donné on
avait diagnostiqué un peu de tension au
passage tu vois les super aura l'autre
ça et du coup j'ai perdu 10 kilos et
c'est parti kwa retraite je pense que
l'acné est ce que c'est un peu c'est un
peu pareil
après chaque cas est différent et comme
vous êtes à leur bon quand tu as du
surpoids ça favorise le déclenchement de
la maladie
mon médecin m'a dit qu'il y avait eu des
équipes qui étaient comme ça et qui en
souffrent air dont elle a exclu ce que
ça peut être ça peut être
vraiment handicapant avec tous les jours
et dangereux quoi vraiment en caisse je
me suis fait peur à plusieurs fois où je
rentrais de tournage et tout ce que j'ai
et je me suis fait peur contre
donc ouais sans parler du fait que à
priori en plus au niveau
cardiovasculaire regagner du coup un peu
d'espérance de vie ça je suis content
pas mal fier je crois que tout est dit
voilà d'ailleurs si vous remercie salut
salut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]